merci merci pour lui vous méritez
beaucoup plus évidemment vous êtes le
footballeur français le plus titré l'un
des footballeurs mondiaux les plus
titrés aussi
de Ligue des champions l'OM en 93 la
Juventus 197 champion de France 90 92
champion d'Italie 95 97 98 Coupe
d'Italie 95 97 Coupe d'Angleterre avec
Chelsea en 2000 champion du monde en 98
champion d'Europe en 2000 recordman des
sélections 103 matchs avec les Bleus et
recordman des matchs comme capitaine 53
sélections mesdames messieurs
un triomphe un triomphe ah ça c'est
consécration
ultime ici ça c'est le top
merci à tous Didier Deschamps donc alors
le seul problème vous avez jamais eu la
Coupe de France j'ai jamais joué de
finale non la seule année aujourd'hui
c'était malheureusement lors des
incidents de Furiani en demi-finale et
donc j'ai pas eu la chance de jouer de
Coupe de France
alors désormais vous êtes reconverti
depuis que vous avez quitté dans les
produits laitiers
à Valence vous jouez à Valence pourquoi
Valence pourquoi être allé jouer à
Valence pourquoi pas en France
mais pour revenir en France il faut être
deux il faut que moi je le veuille je le
voulais mais bon il y a pas des clubs
qui qui l'ont voulu donc c'est difficile
pour moi
j'ai eu des contacts mais bon c'est
difficile avec un titre de champion du
monde et tout cela que ça représente
c'est vrai que c'est pas c'est pas
évident et pour les clubs français à
l'heure actuelle c'est pratiquement
impossible de refaire de refaire revenir
un championnat
alors vous êtes en plus de ça consultant
animateur sur TPS dans une émission qui
s'appelle Deschamps contre champs voilà
et alors vous avez quoi carte blanche
pour parler de foot c'est ça non vous
faites ce que vous voulez oui c'est un
magazine entre 20 et 25 minutes toujours
bien sur l'actualité du football de la
semaine et puis j'ai un invité au
téléphone pendant une dizaine de minutes
en général un joueur ou en entraîneur et
puis quelques petits retours sur la
carrière aussi du match en équipe de
France
un peu moins longue quoi et bien vous
avez un site internet dans le numéro
apparaît en bas de l'écran alors c'est
quoi ce site c'est pour avoir de vos
nouvelles pour ouais pour communiquer
avec avec le public les fans je crois
que ça permet de répondre en direct
d'avoir un contact un peu plus proche
lorsqu'on est à l'étranger c'est moins
évident que lorsqu'on joue dans un club
français donc ça permet de d'être
toujours au courant de l'actualité du
joueur bien alors on va parler un petit
peu de
alors Dominique si des fois il dit pas
la vérité je compte sur vous pour
corriger maintenant vous le connaissez
très très bien donc j'étais en 68 à
Bayonne au Pays Basque jusqu'à la tout
va bien dans un milieu ouvrier votre
mère travaille de 7 heures du matin à 7h
du soir comme vendeuse et votre père il
est peintre à l'aérodrome de Biarritz il
travaillait le samedi et dimanche donc
ça bossait beaucoup chez les méchants
comme nous tous
alors vous manquez de rien mais pas de
superflu quoi
oui ça vous a donné des bonnes bases
tout ça de certains repères comme ça les
valeurs
familiales le l'homme du Pays Basque
enfin voilà c'est carré comme mec quoi
on peut appeler ça comme ça
justement comme vous êtes base quand
j'étais petit vous allez à la chasse à
la pêche comme ça avec votre père et un
jour ils sont venus vous voir pour le
parti pêche chasse et traditions et vous
embarquez parce que vous avez pas
compris que c'est un parti vous donc
je participe pas ça c'est vrai que j'ai
défend ces idées la fin des idées le
fait de la page la pêche la chasse la
nature je suis quelqu'un de très nature
mais hors de question de participer à un
parti politique et puis dans leur liste
bon on met des champs en plus
alors l'état voulait pas en parler le TA
hein non c'est pas un sujet que j'ai
envie d'abord non c'est suffisamment
grave et puis du fait de mon image au
public il vaut mieux pas faire de
commentaires parce que ça sera toujours
mal interprété mais vous avez pas peur
je vais pas dire que j'ai peur mais
lorsque je
vois ce qui est arrivé à mon ami Bixente
Lizarazu c'est vrai que ça ça apporte à
réfléchir et je suis surtout très triste
pour lui et j'espère ne jamais connaître
cette situation
mais est-ce que c'est pas quand même un
peu la terreur là c'est à dire que vous
pouvez pas vous exprimer parce que vous
avez peur de représailles sur votre
famille est-ce qu'ils font pas régner un
peu la Terreur
il y a la peur je m'exprime mais bon en
tant que j'ai une image publique je
préfère ne pas m'exprimer là dessus
il abanderas aussi qui est menace
je savais que ça me toucher le dernier
bien bon alors on continue votre vie
vous avez fait des études au collège
catholique à Bayonne vous étiez doué en
maths en physique et vous dites j'avais
pas fait du foot j'aurais pu faire de la
gestion et l'économie je pense que
j'avais certaines facilités j'ai
continué j'ai continué à préparer par la
suite mais bon j'ai dû m'arrêter pour
incompatibilité avec le football
et alors pourquoi au pays du rugby vous
avez choisi le foot
je sais pas ça c'est venu naturellement
j'ai joué au rugby aussi ça me plaisait
mais je me sentais plus à l'aise avec un
avec un ballon et puis parce que mes
camarades les plus proches jouer au
football donc pour rester avec eux je
joue au football aussi vous commencez
très tôt première licence à l'âge de 12
ans
à l'heure actuelle et à 6 ans 7 ans ils
sont déjà dans des clubs avec des les
parents qui les harcèle au bord du
terrain
au bord du terrain pour les signer le
papa qui voudrait que son fils
absolument un footballeur et puis des
éducateurs qui sont pas toujours
aux Jeunet d'anglais vous dites aucun
joueur pardon d'Anglet
quand votre père vous demande pourquoi
vous allez pas jouer au gêné d'anglais
vous dites aucun joueur n'est jamais
sorti de la barbe vous étiez déjà
vachement motivé parce que déjà dès le
départ vous prenez l'avion Bayonnais et
pas les gêner d'Anglet
je vous le dis parce que souvent vous
avez tendance à dire anglais vous
faites attention
quand vous allez revenir dans la
dès le début vous vivez la réussite non
mais c'est vrai quand même je sais pas
pourquoi je me rappelle avoir dit ça
mais pourtant pour moi le football
c'était pas c'était pas un métier je
voyais pas ça comme devenir
professionnel c'était un jeu mais bon
tant qu'à prendre une licence et être
dans un club autant gagner autant ou
aller dans une équipe qui prennent pas
des raclées tous les week-ends
et alors vous avez perdu une finale de
Coupe d'Aquitaine je possède vous
pleurez après
ça vous touchez ça vous touchez vraiment
ma maman a faisait à l'époque après elle
a arrêté mais à l'époque
vous aussi
j'ai changé un peu de l'attitude je suis
catholique mais bon je suis pas pratique
hein
vous croyez plus ce destin qu'à Dieu
maintenant
bon alors ensuite vous partez en
formation à Nantes un pas à Bordeaux il
faut dire que les mecs de Bordeaux
baisent et que les couilles j'étais venu
chez vos parents en limousine avec des
cigares des grosses mallettes et en
disant à votre père combien vous voulez
pour votre fils c'est vrai que c'était
pas très élégant
mais ça ça donnait tout à fait cette
image là comme on a acheté un bon petit
vous un bon petit cochon
que vous retrouvez à l'âge de 14 ans
seul dans cette grande ville puis en
plus le centre de formation j'imagine
qu'il y a de l'émulation non c'est là
j'ai un peu il faut pas avoir on a une
image un peu dorée du centre de
formation et puis moi je suis arrivé
j'ai eu la malchance qu'on ait parlé
beaucoup de moi qu'on est présenté comme
la future star et je suis arrivé à 15
ans il y avait d'autres joueurs entre 15
et 18 ans et me l'ont fait payer un
petit peu quoi non mais bon ça fait pas
puis j'étais accepté après c'est comme
ça il faut savoir se battre dans tous
les cas là-bas et puis au bout d'un
moment vous commencez à prendre des
cuites avec eux ça devient plus sympa
non une surtout mémorable là ils m'ont
accepté après
et puis vous rencontrez Marcel Desailly
par la suite donc c'est sûr alors déjà
la base j'étais capitaine au centre de
formation vous êtes vraiment un leader
non c'est un chef quoi je sais pas oui
ça c'est fait naturellement je sais pas
ce qu'il faut être pour être chef mais
bon partout je suis passé on m'a confié
des responsabilités dès le début vous
avez été habitué à être en contact avec
la presse avec les médias de par la même
quoi de par le soleil
de vente de la scène donc à partir de là
j'ai très vite compris comment
fonctionnait les médias c'est un
avantage
alors là on arrive à la fiche 69
c'est une tradition dans cette émission
les rôles sont inversés évidemment donc
c'est vous qui allez me poser une
question j'ai une question indiscrète
j'ai une rumeur que j'ai entendu ou si
je voudrais savoir si c'est une légende
est-ce que c'est vrai que vous ne portez
ni caleçon ni un slip
S
elle va être bien votre émission sur tPS
Foot
des champs contre champs
c'est contre Brest saison 1 vous êtes
pas très doué techniquement
c'est ce que j'ai lu dans tous les
nombreux articles que j'ai lu en dit que
vous n'êtes pas bon en dribble pas bon
de la tête vous avez une frappe qui est
pas très puissante
j'ai beaucoup travaillé mais j'ai pas
l'aisance d'un Zidane ou d'en tirer
Henry
non non vraiment pas non
oui tout à l'heure vous avez dit combien
de buts en équipe de France en équipe de
France
24 buts pour le moment pas spécialement
plus ça va moins ça va
plus je recule je vais finir derrière le
gardien
va pas bien je peux plus maintenant
votre génie c'est le placement non vous
savez toujours où il faut être c'est ça
ça fait partie de mon jeu mais bon le
football ça joue quand même avec les
pieds donc c'est pour ça qu'on dit que
bon je suis pas très technique si quand
je dois mettre le ballon à gauche là on
voit toujours à droite je voyais des
problèmes quand même quoi on en reproché
que je récupère beaucoup de ballons que
j'en perdais beaucoup aussi avait au fil
du temps ça c'est amélioré mais bon
j'arrive quand même à faire obéir le
ballon mais il se repère bien sur le
terrain
on l'amène au stade il peut y aller tout
seul
pas avec les médias mais ça va là ça va
mais c'est particulier je réponds pas
des questions de football donc avec moi
il y a pas de danger c'est pas votre
truc
à 20 ans vous êtes capitaine de Nantes
et alors la même saison vous êtes Ben
vous êtes sélectionné pour la première
fois dans les Bleus qui sont à l'époque
coacher par Platini alors Platini vous a
dit un truc sur le comment aller
chercher un trophée moi j'adore cette
histoire c'est à qui vous a dit qu'il
faut prendre son temps il a raison il
m'a dit beaucoup de choses il m'a dit
ouais prends le temps parce que c'est
possible que tu reconnaisses pas encore
ce même plaisir
mais j'ai eu la chance de le connaître
assez souvent quand même mais bon il
faut prendre le plaisir parce que c'est
vraiment un plaisir d'arriver au bout de
gagner une coupe c'est beaucoup de
boulot c'est vrai que quand on reçoit un
trophée que vous aurez votre Molière
vous verrez quand on reçoit un trophée
on y va toujours en courant
c'est ce qu'on me dit mais pourquoi je
sais pas si c'est moi j'ai de bons
rapports avec lui pourtant c'est
quelqu'un que je respecte énormément que
j'ai jamais voulu critiquer parce que il
est pas criticable pour moi mais bon
pourtant quand je le vois quand il est
toujours le sourire
moi aussi mais un privé quoi je me gêne
pas non plus mais ça s'arrête là alors
il a dit que vous étiez un joueur peu
spectaculaire sans génie pas un grand
joueur
jaloux je peux le comprendre sans citer
deux noms mais que Michel Platini soit
comme ça non pour moi c'est pas possible
vous qu'est-ce que vous en pensez parce
que étudier le problème pendant de longs
mois
bon après vous êtes vendus à l'OM alors
j'adore le toujours le côté maquignon
on t'a vendu Didier ça sera à Marseille
ils avaient besoin d'argent l'époque ils
étaient en difficulté c'était le
président le regretté max Bouillet et il
m'a appris ça oui au soir d'un match en
équipe de France je joue à Toulouse
vendu voilà
vous arrivez à Marseille
alors lui en plus il croit pas en vous
sur au départ oui
après six mois après parce que j'ai eu
un départ fulgurant et puis après un peu
le trou noir
Bernard Tapie lui dit chez moi tu
réussiras pas vaut mieux que tu partes
sympa
c'est ce qu'il pensait
quand il m'a redonné ma chance donc
c'est qu'au fond de lui
vous êtes battus vous avez discuté avec
lui pendant au moins une heure et demie
je me suis accroché au téléphone je dis
parce que pour moi à partir du moment
j'avais signé un contrat à l'OM il était
hors de question il fallait que je
m'impose alors ça c'était clair et donc
je suis revenu et puis mais après il m'a
facilité la tâche quand même il m'a
donné ma chance après vous imposé avec
deux Saïd d'ailleurs et puis vous
finissez capitaine et puis après la
Coupe d'Europe des clubs champions à
Munich
jusque là tout va bien au prieuré
l'histoire de la Coupe du Monde 94 moi
j'étais au Parc des Princes
malheureusement à quelle heure je te
jure on mettait les manteaux et à ce
moment-là
c'était terrible il y avait des gens qui
étaient pas en bleu blanc rouge comme ça
avec les larmes qui coulaient sur le
bleu blanc rouge et tout c'était une
image d'une force c'était terrible pour
vous mais pour nos joueurs
de ma carrière
et là comme par hasard c'est bon on peut
pas aller plus bas donc c'est le début
de la remontée avec avec Jacquet alors
d'abord c'est cantonal capitaine des
Bleus
comme footballeur comme être humain
comme acteur il fait marrer
aussi
votre charisme et puis vous remplacez
donc Cantona disons qu'il a eu des
discussions avec
Eric Cantona il avait des choix à faire
et à partir du moment où il a pas pris
Eric il a dû s'appuyer sur sur une autre
personne il a fait le tour un peu des
anciens et puis il m'a confié le concert
de capitaine
il était dans une fête il a fait
attendre Jacquet pendant deux heures
c'est vrai
remplace Cantona Papin sur l'Euro 96 et
la grande équipe de France se met peu à
peu près et non pas le fait que je sois
moi capitaine
quand on a je sais pas vous qui les fait
virer quand même non j'ai pas ce pouvoir
là non
pour lui pendant 5 ans donc
c'est pas j'ai
couru
et puis voilà et on arrive à laisser 98
du tout je me suis prise je vais dire
demi-finales et tout ça à klaxonné dans
la voiture comme une andouille alors que
j'aurais trouvé ça stupide six mois
avant et c'est vraiment on était tout
seul avec vous pourquoi tout l'argent
depuis la libération mais malgré ça vous
êtes très critiqué sur la préparation de
l'Euro 2000 vous décidez de plus parler
à la presse
simplement les critiques les critiques
je les ai toujours accepté elles font
partie du métier comme on dit mais
lorsqu'on en arrive à ce que ça soit des
articles malsains ou avoir jusqu'à
l'incompétence bon ça ne m'intéressait
pas de répondre à certaines personnes
malheureusement c'était pas la majorité
des journalistes et je le regrette pour
lui dire
en particulier
qui ont cherché à la victoire que vous
aviez obtenue avec l'équipe de France à
la Coupe du Monde comment dans les
années qui ont suivi vous pouvez être
autant critiqué les Guignols qu'on va
mettre une couche comme le dissip bien
aimé Jacquet comment non mais comment ça
se fait comment vous expliquer ça à vous
l'image des Guignols parce que j'avais
pas quelque chose de particulier qui
pouvait me faire entrer dans le mien
mais je crois pas que je l'ai dit
souvent cette phrase et mets Jacky
heureusement l'a dit lui-même c'est vrai
que j'ai souvent eu des accrochages avec
lui parce qu'on n'était pas forcément
d'accord mais bon c'est pas bien méchant
mais les critiques c'est comme ça on a
été champion du monde et on a une une
période de qualification pour l'Euro qui
a été très difficile où on nous disait
il fallait changer tout le monde et il y
avait que des donneurs de leçons les
mêmes qui avaient critiqué avant la
Coupe du Monde et après ils étaient
obligés de reconnaître que c'était quand
même un bon entrepreneur et vous
oui le maire évidemment dans la lignée
du Jacquet et puis certainement moi
aussi parce que bon j'étais un peu le
l'héritier de Jacquet on était blessé
par les propos d'un coéquipier qui a dit
en parlant de vous Didier il est cramé
et le 2 septembre votre dernier match
donc vous allez le voir et vous lui
dites je sais exactement les propos que
tu as tenu sur moi
je voulais c'est qui ce type
c'est un des joueurs non j'ai pas envie
le fait que je me sois éliminé c'est à
dire que j'ai laissé l'équipe de France
ça pose plus aucun problème vu que bon
il peut continuer moi je continue pas si
j'avais eu à continuer ça aurait
certainement poser des problèmes parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui qui m'a trahi et
j'aime pas ça surtout de l'Intérieur
lui aussi il le sait puisque je lui ai
dit et vous moi j'ai mis huit mois avant
de le savoir mais je vais vous le dire
c'est
il est là ce soir
c'est pas possible
c'est difficile
c'est incroyable c'est-à-dire que la
première fois dans très content mais là
la deuxième fois 2 ans après la c'est
trop ah c'est un truc là
[Rires]
parce que ça a été beaucoup plus
difficile et de confirmer face à des
adversaires plus
plus du rabattre aussi donc ça a été
vraiment ce serait contenté d'une fois
vous nous l'avez offert deux fois la
victoire c'est génial
dès maintenant
et alors à la fin de ce match j'avais
une conversation avec Roger Lemaire
discrète discrète
là je me suis ce que vous lui disiez
s'il y en a qui ont cherché
que vous partez
bourru là têtu
autour de ce sujet là mais bon
certainement pas j'allais pas lancer
après une victoire comme ça ça aurait
été trop facile puis non j'avais pas
envie je voulais profiter de ce moment
de bonheur avec mes camarades et puis
savourer surtout cette là j'ai vraiment
savourer parce que je savais à la fin du
coup de sifflet final que c'était
certainement mon dernier télégram avec
l'équipe nationale alors bon vous partez
à Valence là donc problème physique
évidemment prennent de confiance non
c'est possible tout dépend pour la
première fois je
j'ai introduit dans mon esprit la notion
de plaisir par rapport au jeu et donc
j'ai pas j'ai deux ans il me reste 200 à
jouer et donc j'ai envie de prendre du
plaisir et de jouer et donc si c'est
pour rester à Valence et être assis
comme ce soir ça m'intéresse pas
beaucoup donc on verra comment ça se
passe en fin de saison
médiatique
ou non mais moi j'ai eu l'avantage
peut-être par rapport à d'autres
footballeurs d'avoir une vie avant cette
victoire en Coupe du monde donc bon je
suis pas passé d'une extrême à l'autre
ça a été plus difficile pour certains
joueurs qui sont passés
d'une période où ils étaient pas très
connus à être des stars bien maintenant
Didier Deschamps
je vais jouer avec la Juve vous avez été
entendu par un juge d'instruction
turinois pour des problèmes de d'usage
de dopage disons de créatine qu'en
est-il exactement mais j'ai été
confronté trois fois oui c'est vrai
injuste d'instruction qui qui avant même
de poser des questions étaient persuadé
que
il y avait du dopage dans le football
qu'on utilisait le PO donc c'est très
difficile de de faire face à un tel
personnage la créatine aussi c'est vrai
qu'elle est utilisée l'autoriser dans un
pays de certains pays dans d'autres non
j'en ai pris pendant une certaine
période après j'ai arrêté je pense pas
que ça soit un produit nocif même si
certains spécialistes le disent mais le
dopage en règle générale et je pense
qu'il y en a dans le sport dans le
football j'ai pas été confronté parce
que je pense sincèrement je vois pas
l'utilité je vois pas que le dopage
contre un produit peut
d'un joueur bidon peut faire un super
joueur ça jamais fait tirer dans les
lucarnes donc tu vas pas te l'utilité ça
peut faire courir plus vite ça peut être
plus résistant mais il y a le ballon et
le ballon c'est les pieds il faut savoir
le diriger donc très souvent même temps
donc la répétition évidemment qu'on a
des des aides au niveau pharmaceutique
pour aider à récupérer mais ce juge là
il partait du principe moi c'est ce qui
m'a dit en fin de d'interrogatoire il me
dit je voudrais arriver à faire une loi
que le footballeur s'y prend un produit
une vitamine C peu importe où on est
enrhumé ou qui prend quelque chose la
semaine avant le match ils ne puisse pas
jouer un match il y aurait plus beaucoup
de football à la télé sincèrement merci
de votre sincérité vivez les champs la
question qui tue
donc Didier Deschamps vous confirmez
c'est comme à la télé pas de dopage dans
le football bien alors maintenant je
vous fais tant pis pour vous une
interview nulle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai peur que vous soyez baffiste vous
absolument
familiale
je pourrais prendre plein de main là il
y a pas de problème
alors est-ce que vous préférez pierre ou
Ginette
j'avais dit que c'était con
c'est on parle des mêmes parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup de pierres votre pierre
votre papa pierre et votre maman Ginette
on peut pas faire un choix entre ses
parents
les deux donc non je peux pas choisir
sincèrement vous arrivez pas là non non
non
vous en foutez c'est pas vos parents là
heureusement
c'est pareil je vois pas de différence
bien alors vous partez dans un vaisseau
spatial pendant trois ans je crains de
pire
avec non c'est le vaisseau spatial avec
qui vous préférez partir quand on a
tapis ou locaux
beaucoup de vérités est-ce que vous
préférez mourir tout de suite là
maintenant là pas vraiment et aller au
paradis
ou vivre 30 ans de plus et aller en
enfer je prends les 30 ans
pour aller à la pêche
[Musique]
c'est vraiment con j'ai répondu je sais
pas moi avec la fille quand même filtrer
ça doit être la même à mon avis parce
que alors le monde
spatial en plus si vous saviez le nombre
de films
en disant moi si Samuel Le Bihan veut
une fille moche c'est moi qui Guillaume
Canet veut une fille moche je suis
d'accord une fois il est quoi vous
pariez fille moche ou mec non mais vous
c'est l'inverse je m'excuse
là c'est la question très très con là
j'ai pas inversé
très belle et forcément très con
je vous souhaite ça m'arrange
cela est terrible vous préférez adopter
des jumeaux cleptomane ou des jumelles
pyromane
j'avais averti en même temps
vous vivez en plus
à la maison
ensuite de tibéry ou en slip de la Noé
[Rires]
en fait par un quand c'est de la Noël
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu